مفترق طرق وضعت فيه العمليه العسكريه
التركيه مخلب السيف كل من روسيا والولايات
المتحده وتركيا وساحه التدرب المواقف هي
سوريا في مناطقها الشماليه الشرقيه
تمت خلافات مؤكده بين انقره وموسكو بشان
التحرك التركي قال المتحدث باسم الكريم
لندمتري ديسكو لكنها من نوع الخلافات التي
يمكن حلها بالحكمه السياسيه ليس الموقف
الروسي وليد الساعه فقد سبق بدا تركيا
عمليتها العسكريه عندما طلبت موسكو من
انقره الامتناع عن شم هجوم بري شامل لان
ذلك قد يؤدي الى تصاعد العنف من وجهه نظر
الروس
يتهم الرسل الولايات المتحده بانها وراء
تاليب المسلحين الاكراد الذين تعتبرهم
انقره تهديدا لامنها فقد قال مبعوث الرئيس
الروسي الى الشرق الاوسط وشمالي افريقيا
اليكساندر لافرنتيف ان الغرب يعتبر سوريا
جبهه اضافيه ضد روسيا في ظل استمرار الحرب
في اوكرانيا لكن الولايات المتحده ايضا
عارضت العمليه العسكريه
بوقتها فورا لانها من منظور امريكي تهدد
امن الجنود الامريكيين ففي مواقع قوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه التي يستهدفها القصف
التركي يتوزع حوالي 900 جندي امريكي في
اطار التحالف الدولي ضد تنظيم الدوله الذي
يشكل الاكراد حجرا اساسيا فيها رغم ذلك
سبق للبيت الابيض ان ابدى موقفا متفهما
لبواعث القلق التركي وقال انه يحق للاتراك
الدفاع عن انفسهم من اي تهديد ارهابيه
ايا كانت المواقف فان الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان بدا حازما عازما على المضيق
قدما عندما قال ان لبلاده حقا مشروعه وانه
ليس لاحد ان يقف امام ممارسه حقها
على الارض وصلت القوات التركيه قصف مواقع
من وصفتهم بالارهابيين شمالي سوريا
والعراق وحددت مصادر اعلاميه قريبه من حزب
العمال الكردستاني اهداف القصف التركي في
مطار ريف حلب وقريه عين دقنه في منطقه
الشهباء وقريه مرعناز في عفرين بينما قال
المركز الاعلامي لقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
ان ضربات بالقذائف والهاون والدبابات
استهدفه الفرات وعين العرب كوباني وتل
ابيض باكثر من 400 قذيفه تطورات رافقها
تحرك وزير الدفاع التركي خلوسي اكار الذي
التقى قادت الجيش في مدينتها كاري على
الحدود العراقيه لمتابعه مجريات العمليتين
العسكريتين التركيتين في سوريا والعراق